>> THERE IS BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT, THE FIRST CONCRETE
STEP TOWARDS CONSEQUENCES FOR A
CONGRESSMAN WHO PUT OUT A
PHOTOSHOPPED ANIME VIDEO
DEPICTING HIMSELF MURDERING A
COWORKER AND ATTACKING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
10 HOUSE DEMOCRATS TONIGHT
ANNOUNCING THEY WILL ANNOUNCE A
RESOLUTION TO PAUL GOSAR,
UNCLEAR WHETHER IT WILL BE
LOOKING AT A VOTE --
AS FOR THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN
LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY, THERE
HAVE BEEN NO ANIME VIDEOS OF
HIM SPRINGING INTO ACTION.
THERE WASN'T EVEN A SILENT
MOVIE, OR A SINGLE PEOPLE FOR
THAT MATTER.
LEADER MCCARTHY HAD NOTHING TO
SAY AT ALL ABOUT CONGRESSMAN
GOSAR'S VIDEO AT ALL AGAINST
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, AND THE
PRESIDENT.
GOSAR TOOK IT DOWN FROM SOCIAL
MEDIA, BUT THAT IS NO LONGER
THE MAIN ISSUE WHICH IS THE
DEAFENING SILENCE OF HIS
PARTY'S LEADERSHIP ON IT, WHICH
REALLY SHOULDN'T COME AS A
SHOCK.
THE GOP THESE DAYS WITH RARE
EXCEPTION IS NOT A PARTY ALL
THAT KEEN ON SELF EXAMINATION.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
OBNOXIOUS AND CRUDE, OR EVEN
OUTRIGHT THREATENING BEHAVIOR
TOWARD COLLEAGUES OR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> LET'S GO BRANDON.
>> BILL POSING POSING, HE ENDED
HIS REMARKS WITH A RIGHT-WING
MEME FOR JOE BIDEN, NO
CONSEQUENCES FOR HIM IN HIS
PARTY, HE DID IT IN A
LACKLUSTER WAY.
HE DIDN'T REALLY PUT HIS HEART
INTO, IT IT DIDN'T SEEM.
REMEMBER WHEN REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN JOE WILSON SHOUTED
YOU LIVE, THAT WAS CONSIDERED
SHOCKING.
HE FACED NO CONSEQUENCES THIS
WILL FROM HIS PARTY WHICH
BACKED DOWN OVERWHELMINGLY
AGAINST A DISAPPROVAL, AS FOR
THE PRIORITIES THIS TIME,
REPUBLICANS INCLUDING LEADER
MCCARTHY CERTAINLY HAVE HAD
TIME TO DRUM CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ
CHENEY OUT OF HER LEADERSHIP
POSITION.
SHE HAS BEEN SEEKING OUT THE
TRUTH ABOUT JANUARY 6TH.
WE END BIDEN MCCARTHY ON THE
PROGRAM FOR THE 2ND TIME IN
MANY DAYS, JUST LIKE HIS
RESPONSE TO THE GOSAR
CONTROVERSY, HE DIDN'T HEAR
ANYTHING.
GLORIA, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
PLAN FOR A DEMOCRAT-LED
RESOLUTION TO CENSURE
CONGRESSMAN GOSAR?
DOESN'T GO ANYWHERE?
THE THOUGHT HAPPEN?
>> WE ARE NOT SURE IF IT IS
GOING TO GO ANYWHERE.
THEY'RE GOING TO INTRODUCE IT
ON FRIDAY.
IT COMES FROM THE DEMOCRATS, IT
WAS DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED TO
STRIP MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE OF
HER COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS, WHO
SAID THIS WILL NOT STAND, AND
THEY PUT THAT ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR.
SO CLEARLY THEY BELIEVE
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE.
BUT AS YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
JUST A MOMENT AGO, WHERE IS
KEVIN MCCARTHY?
THIS IS ABOUT LEADERSHIP.
THIS IS ABOUT HIS LEADERSHIP
TEAM.
THIS IS ABOUT HOW A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS OUGHT TO BEHAVE, NOT
ABOUT, WELL, WILL THIS HURT ME?
DONALD TRUMP LIKES GOSAR, I
WANT TO BE THE NEXT SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE, AND ON, AND ON.
THERE IS A MORAL OBLIGATION IT
WOULD SEEM TO ME TO SPEAK OUT
AND SAY, THIS CANNOT STAND.
THIS PERSON NEEDS TO LEARN A
LESSON HERE, AND OF COURSE
MCCARTHY DOESN'T WANT TO DO
THAT.
>> I HAVE NOT HEARD THE TERM
MORAL OBLIGATION IN RELATION TO,
I DON'T SAY THIS WITH ANY PRIDE,
IN RELATION TO A LOT OF FOLKS
IN CONGRESS OF LATE.
>> IT IS NO SURPRISE THAT WE
ARE HERE, THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF
USED THREATENING LANGUAGE
AGAINST MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
ANYONE HE DEEMED AN ENEMY,
WHICH WAS THE MEDIA, WHICH WAS
INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS, WHICH
WERE DIPLOMATS, I MEAN IT
DIDN'T REALLY MATTER.
ANYONE WHO CAME ACROSS HIS PATH
WASN'T AN EMMY, AND HE REALLY
ROLLED PEOPLE UP TO TURN
AGAINST THEIR OWN NEIGHBORS.
UNSURPRISINGLY, THEY DID.
THERE IS ANOTHER LAYER HERE,
ANDERSON, WHICH IS ONE OF
MISOGYNY, AND WOMEN IN ANY KIND
OF PUBLIC EYE GET THIS SORT OF,
THEY GET THE DEATH FANTASIES,
RAPE FANTASIES, I HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT OF SOME OF THESE.
THEY'RE AWFUL.
CONSERVATIVES, REALLY USED TO
RAIL AGAINST THAT KIND OF
MISOGYNY WHEN IT CAME TO
POLITICAL FIGURES LIKE KEITH
OVERMINE OR EVEN RUSSIA
LIMBAUGH.
WOMEN THOUGH NEVER SHOULD
EXPECT TO GET THAT FROM A
SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
THAT IS THE SHOCKING PART, THAT
A SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS
PUT OUT A VIDEO WHERE AND HE IN
AN UNABATED WAY KILLS A WOMAN
IN CONGRESS.
I MEAN, IT IS SHOCKING.
AND AGAIN, AND SURPRISING
BECAUSE NOBODY EVER EXPECTED A
SITTING PRETTY SUDDEN TO DO
THAT KIND OF, TO USE THAT KIND
OF MISOGYNISTIC LANGUAGE
AGAINST WOMEN, AND YET HE DID.
>> GLORIA, PAUL GOSAR HAS A
LONG LIST OF REPREHENSIBLE
THINGS, WE ARE NOT EVEN TALKING
ABOUT POLITICALLY, I'M JUST
TALKING ABOUT FROM A HUMAN
STANDPOINT.
HE HAS BEEN PRETTY
REPREHENSIBLE OF LATE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG BACK IT
GOES, I HAVE ONLY BEEN PINK
ATTENTION TO HIM FOR A YEAR OR
SO.
HOW DO YOU SQUARE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WANTING TO
PUNISH ITS MEMBERS FOR VOTING
TO FIX BRIDGES AND ROADS, BUT
NOT PUNISH THEM FOR PRODUCING A
VIDEO LIKE THIS?
>> IT DEFIES EXPLANATION.
I MEAN, HERE THEY ARE, FINALLY
GETTING SOME BIPARTISANSHIP ON
CAPITOL HILL, BUT YOU HAVE
DONALD TRUMP OUT HERE, AND I
GUESS HE IS THE REASON.
DONALD TRUMP OUT HERE SAYING,
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WHO VOTED
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE, YOU HAVE
GOT TO DEFEAT THEM.
YOU HAVE MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
GIVING OUT THEIR PHONE NUMBERS.
WHY?
DON'T FORGET, I WAS JUST
THINKING ABOUT THIS TODAY,
DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF SIGNED ON
TO IN THEORY A 2 TRILLION
DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN WHEN
HE WAS PRESIDENT UNTIL HE
WALKED OUT ON THE DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE HE WAS MAD THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING HIM.
BUT HE WAS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE,
AND HOW THE DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR
IT.
WHY?
THEY DO NOT WANT TO GIVE JOE
BIDEN A WIN ON ANYTHING.
TRUMP CAME OUT AND SAID THAT,
AND SO REPUBLICANS ARE JUST
FOLLOWING.
BECAUSE, THEY DO NOT KNOW ANY
OTHER WAY AT THIS POINT.
IT IS REALLY DEPRESSING,
ACTUALLY.
>> IS IT GOING TO PAY OFF?
THE GAMBLE THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP IS MAKING RIGHT NOW?
IS NOT GOING TO PAY OFF
POLITICALLY?
>> PROBABLY.
THERE DOES NOT SEEM TO BE ANY
PAIN OR ANGER, OR DIVISION THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE NOT WILLING TO
EXPLOIT, AND MANIPULATE.
TO COLLECT BOATS, TO PLEASE
TRUMP, TO REMAIN IN POWER.
SO, I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
WHERE THEY WON'T GO.
NOWHERE IS OFF LIMITS.
I JUST THINK, I FEAR, AND I
JUST KNOW, THIS IS GOING TO END
BADLY.
AND VIOLENTLY.
I WONDER IF THAT IS WHAT IT
WILL TAKE FOR REPUBLICANS TO
STOP TURNING AMERICANS AGAINST
AMERICANS.
WE ALREADY SAW THE VIOLENCE IT
WRECKED, IT WREAKED AT THE
CAPITOL.
WE HAVE SEEN VIOLENCE.
IS IT WHAT IS GOING TO TAKE FOR